[Music]
hey guys welcome back to author record
where we talk about
wait wow and we got cat here
you may know her from king and the sting
yeah spider and the kid yes two podcasts
that are really good
so how did you get connected with them
because i d m'd
brandon shop like 50 times [ __ ]
because i dm'd him once
and then you got on the show forever
yeah and i've been on the show ever
since
incredible that's what happens when you
have a vagina just kidding who did you
say in your dms
to him honestly i'm going to read it
yeah read them all up oh yeah [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
start with can you come can you come
please to be fair he had david on
uh fighter and the kids see that's not
failed i know i think your chances are
much higher why is david on that show
because he's more desperate now so he's
probably gonna bring us on
damn man uh i think gianni was the one
who set it up
gianni he's on power
yeah stupid idiot that guy wait didn't
we box with him yeah yeah he's trained
with us
very handsome guy i wrote what up man
just wanted to say i'm a big fan and you
inspire me oh that's why
2018. you're too much of a fan dude you
got to be an equal man
first [ __ ] rule of networking man
guess what i'm gonna talk some [ __ ] talk
some [ __ ] i'm right [ __ ] you
i used to be the one who uh did all of
his social media for a while um
so she wasn't responding to your thirsty
ass she would swipe into it i started in
2019 doing that for him but now i don't
even do that
uh yeah now it's actually gianni
jonathan
gianni's like [ __ ] god we know
him dude i'm reading your [ __ ] and
saying [ __ ] you bart
are you guys in the same building with
theo still not anymore uh
theo and uh us we all moved out of that
building
and now we're in like separate parts of
town it was fun when we were in
like right next door to each other yeah
yeah one of us is recording the other
one knocking the door and like
awesome [ __ ] it was hella small like
it's way smaller in real life
it's a closet yeah there was some
[ __ ] with the building though i
heard
yeah yeah pretty interesting
the old building or uh the current
building
the one that you guys were all in
together oh that was like a shared space
and it was near the youtube space
oh i think about the second one then
second one
[Music]
[Applause]
way [ __ ] bigger in real life than i
thought too
yeah yeah cause uh i saw him like when i
was on theo's thing
who brendan yeah yeah oh yeah he's a
piece of big [ __ ] i was like
man when you're sitting down you look
way smaller
i mean still big but way smaller he was
a d1 football player right and then he
went to the ufc
yeah yeah chin is huge too chin is about
maybe like an inch or two shorter than
him i saw him standing next to david
yeah i saw him next to david i'm like
what the [ __ ] chin is probably like
steve's
height no no no no steve's probably six
four and a half
in your face oh you're like brendan's
height then yeah he was taller
hey our crow's taller on average maybe
on average maybe yeah
we average everything out i'm i'm five
four yeah i'm a whole yeah he's a whole
whole foot
not that crazy when you think i'm a big
boy
big boy i know a guy who's uh six
six so he's a whole foot above me what a
waist though on me though why
why why give me that kind of height well
no because like what i ended up doing
okay i can't
i can't [ __ ] do athletics at all you
have a sport yeah i like to watch sports
though i don't need to have this
this tall of a frame to watch outdoors
you could see over people at concerts i
know
aren't actors usually short like taller
actors are kind of the exceptions yeah
dude my understanding like gianni is
kind of like the standard for an actor
like is he really
five ten most actors i've met personally
gianni's five
six bro a lot of action stars are short
right
like stallone no dude jason i was like
five foot even
yes he is jason was like 411 i think
that's so crazy because
you think he'd be a lot different yeah
khaleesi is three feet actually yeah
dude she's small
and tyrion's two feet dude he's just
exactly like hammer tricks right
he's the size of this drink you have to
film it like the [ __ ] hobbit
yeah you guys are hilarious wait so
who's your most favorite celebrity
you've met then
um i think joe coy joe coy is
so nice and wholesome and i think i
started watching
joe coy on netflix shortly before or
during
my time with fighter and the kid and i
was so i'm so attracted to like old
filipino men
i was like like i thought he was
gorgeous and like nobody else in the
studio quite understood it they're like
you think joe coy's not like hell yeah i
think joko is hot i've never told him
this though so joe if you're watching
this i'm so sorry
i'm so
middle-aged filipino dudes that watch
this and they're probably like
what they exist out there i could get
myself
a young cutie yes but they got to be
funny right hottest
dante oh yeah i had a crush but dante's
been hot all his life he's always been
hot he's
always been fine as [ __ ] it's kind of
not fair the first time i met him i was
like this dude's a dream you got a raspy
voice
yeah it's that voice how did he have a
smoker's voice at 12 years old dude i
know
yes he's got a little grain nice
so hot and he got even hotter yeah yeah
yeah i
mean it's weird because like we know him
right and we're like pretty good friends
or whatever and then
you know i'm married right you're cute
and then i told you not when she's on
the show though
yeah she's always like yeah dante's over
here is
this is the show notes over here let me
help you get um your phone here
it's locked yeah no way coffee
no you are you are but but before i met
casey before i was married
when i was younger and i saw hook he was
actually my first like asian crush
really i never told dante damn he was
your first fetish huh yeah
yeah yeah it's really weird but yeah i'm
all i'm saying
you you should bring yourself saying
that you should be like yo i used to
masturbate to you
most chicks loved the young peter pan in
that movie i heard more about that
kid than i ever [ __ ] heard about
anything really when i was that age
i can't remember like the young one he's
not
staring at himself in the water the
whole time no we all get wet for uh
oh my god especially mrs doubtfire right
yeah this doubt fire robin
the cake scene hello oh yeah that is
but no i was a child there's no way i
didn't even know what it meant to like
have a crush
there's no there's no judgment zone so
it's all yeah it's okay i'm just
clarifying that's it
i think my first crush was probably uh
no
uh nola nola from from lion king
[Laughter]
biting his lip watching lion king that
nola bro
[ __ ] cheeks and [ __ ] like damn
because you didn't get the name it's
like you fell on your head doing
gymnastics
i forgot it nola nola
movie like which one i mean everything
yeah jane striptease
g.i j underrated they should have shot
that one naked i think
i don't know you're more pure i agree
have you seen her uh bush photo from
like way back in the day
like george bush no uh demi moore did a
like
i don't know if it was completely nude
but i was like partially nude photo
shoot when she was younger like in her
heydays of like i'm [ __ ] demi moore
and she was she basically had like a
huge
bush like bush bush bush and it's
[ __ ] crazy because i would look at
that and i'm like it's like bart's
in my head it's like demi moore is like
this beautiful ethereal woman and then
like
she has this crazy bush which there's
nothing wrong with it back then
i didn't think she would do a photo
shoot like that even back in the day
yeah because more of her showing the
bush than her having the bush
yeah i suddenly when i saw that like two
months ago i was like oh demi moore's so
[ __ ] hot
how many bushes did she have was it
three bushes i would say like it's the
amount of i take
two men's like uh underarm hair
she had bushes here too like bush no so
she shows her armpit but not her couch
couch
yes everything else is shaved but not
her couch i need to see i need a safe
search from that one
oh yeah you need to turn that one off
for that i want to see it
it looked like a loin cloth let me break
she probably shaved off right after the
shoot too
she was like i'm done i'm imagining it
was like that ikea sheep fur
like that but black yeah she took bruce
willis's hair and
it did disappear during that period i
always felt like man if i was bruce
willis
and my wife left me for someone that's
half my age like [ __ ]
did you hear that bruce like it was like
strange you guys want to see it yeah
yeah of course all right let's see
i'm making it give me more give me more
give me more give me more about demi
moore ready yeah i'm ready
here it is that's her what you blurted
out but like she did like an
open like disappointment
in her eyes why is she a communist
what's wrong with the female body
huh what's wrong with that women's
bodies nothing's wrong with female
bodies
thank you that's what i said this is
pretty out there but anyway
this episode is brought to you by feels
so for a lot of people i think cbd helps
with reducing anxiety
uh some pain some sleeplessness i
actually use it
in a non-traditional way so i've been
told and i think it's because
i have like crazy 80d yeah that my
uh that geo can feel when we're having
sex if i'm in the moment or not
yeah so like she's like you're
distracted you're thinking about
pinocchio
now pinocchio but i can think about
myself having sex rather than just
having sex
does that make sense you know sometimes
you're like aware but you're like third
person you're like yeah wait i'm nervous
right now instead of just being nervous
oh yeah so
sometimes it's good but then when you're
in when you're having sex you want to be
in the moment
and you want to just kind of like take
the edge off and not have so much like i
guess sex anxiety
it helps yeah so i placed a few drops
underneath my tongue and helped me get
in the mood and help me be in the moment
so i'm not so much in my own thoughts
and the sex is way better real i'm gonna
jack off tonight with cbd
yeah damn and use the oils and [ __ ] you
might be too
up it's not enough does it kind of numb
your balls i don't know but i might as
well try do have all the stuff yeah
everything yeah
yeah i got i'm gonna try some cbd oil in
my tongue
and [ __ ] beat off like no tomorrow
man see if that works it's been helping
with my sex life and what's cool about
fields is you can order it it comes
right to your door it's freaking awesome
that's the cool part
so also feels offers a cbd hotline
and i'm probably not going to call them
while i'm doing
sexual things to myself but maybe before
to help guide me in the process of
taking cbd scientifically obviously
not sexually because i don't want to do
that to the operator and i'm sure they
got a very sexy voice but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna traumatize them that way
and uh
i think what's cool is if you're new to
this
which i was you know you can just be
like yo how much am i supposed to take
like
should i just do one drop or like
whatever or like if you have any
questions you have a
somebody on the other side there to kind
of help you out through the whole
process
which is very helpful especially if
you're trying it for the first time
so if you want to feel a little bit
better or if you're like me we're kind
of caught up in your own thoughts a
little bit too much
try feels.com off the record because you
get 50
off your first order f-e-a-l-s-com
off the record to get 50 off plus free
shipping
just because we're scientists stupid
picture
[Laughter]
bart wants to see nala next that's what
you i think she
no longer bro wait what was so hot about
yeah we gotta talk away the way like her
eyes were and like the way she was like
like uh simba like rolling around
like these like seductive ass eyes oh
you should have censored it
that would have been sick i don't have
those problems because she wants it
bro i have all things you could have
said you chose [ __ ] maybe i thought i
was an
animal i don't know how do you feel
about nala in the live action
i haven't seen it it's hot in that i
haven't seen it yet have you heard of
the furry community yeah
oh yeah they want to [ __ ] stuff animal
peoples
yep you don't want to beyonce when i
watch the live-action movie i was like
all i'm hearing is beyonce that's all
i'm hearing i'm not i can't even be in
this lion king her voice is too unique
huh
it's very just look for you huh yeah
yeah that's the [ __ ] one the one on
the right because you know her butt is
in the air
with the [ __ ] eyes oh yeah it is they
[ __ ] me down daddy they know what
they're doing
yeah yeah yeah that's back and then you
got you got elton john in the background
he's like man the mood was set come on
you know
come on dude that's true we were
watching [ __ ] animal [ __ ] you know it
said
sex in the sky what yeah in the lion
king
that's in the lyrics no no no no no no
in the lion king
the sex industries
in the lion king when he like lays on
the grass and then like a whole bunch of
like dust comes up it smells out sex
what yeah you never said can you google
that yes that's some conspiracy theory
subliminally
message us like this they did a bunch
adults to want to [ __ ] a lioness
yeah yeah it says s-e-x
wait what's a stretch
this is like i'm watching ghost hunters
and like oh you know what she just said
she said i'm gonna kill i'm gonna kill
and and then we hear it and it's like
wait wait no
there's a lot of these wait that's how
you read no it literally says sex on
there and then the other one too
and this is only in the vhs of aladdin
there's this one where no dude i know
so there's this one moment where uh you
can actually hear really faintly
in the background in the audio it says
uh
come on kids take off your clothes or it
says something like that oh i remember
wearing that one which one what move is
that aladdin and then there's a little
mermaid
on the vhs cover it of the castle it
actually has a shape of a dick in there
and there's a dead fish with a belt
around his neck
yeah no girls i swear to you disney was
trying to get kids to [ __ ] for so long
yeah
they're trying i feel like it's a
disgruntled disney employee right here
that's just the truth i need a penis
where right here oh yeah that's a dick
that's a dick
if you zoom in like that oh my god it's
hidden it's a subliminal message kind of
what oh my god it's really you know what
it is though it's really just like
years later they're at a party it's like
hey you know i drew a [ __ ] dick
yeah you gotta see this [ __ ] it was like
they zoom
in on it and like and like wow you did
draw a dick on that dude good job
that's all it is and you see the like oh
spot the hidden mickeys like spot the
hidden dicks yeah
yeah and it's the same thing but
everyone does this thing like oh
they're trying to like teach kids to
[ __ ] and make them like more likely to
want to [ __ ]
older people and i'm like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about it makes more
sense that one person was behind it as a
prank
than like so many people it's a
conspiracy consortium
look at this one get kids to [ __ ] so the
lion king
is shaped like a girl's back with their
ass wearing a thong
what it's also shaped like a guy with a
like a bunny with a mask
like a like a ninja buddy yeah yeah you
know me like it could be anything
i don't see the bunny like like a
bunny's nose with the and then that's
the ears like that like a ninja bunny
right like
yeah yeah i don't know i only see ass
that's all i could do well maybe you're
just a little too horny you're very
lucky
maybe you're pervert did was did was tim
burton the one that drew all those
dicks and stuff timber because he was uh
his story was he used to be an intern
at disney i think he was weird no one
liked to talk to him he was the guy
who's drawing like weird [ __ ] like
mickey mouse all weird and
like all the characters the classic
characters all weird and then they're
like this guy's not a fit
not a really good fit for us and then i
think he went off to do his own thing
and he
created his own genius and then that's
when disney brought him back i feel like
tim burton was the kid that always drew
like everybody with their heads chopped
off
yeah but like in a real cool way though
yeah like really yeah
and in goth form and then he never
stopped doing it yeah and he just does
it every time i know
and then he always casts his wife with
johnny depp yeah every time what's up
with that weird that's
weird you like it i'm into it dude do
you think he sees hell in the bottom
carter by the pool he's like get the
[ __ ] out of the sun
like you're gonna ruin my movie
she needs to stay pale she is the most
pale woman i've ever seen
he loves pale doesn't he he loves that
whole aesthetic it's too pale
i can't watch any of his movies i saw
photos of him working at disney as an
intern and he already looked the same
like just all black
clothes like really yeah he's been a
vampire huh
not making this up no no i was watching
i forgot i was watching but it was like
um
something about like showing you how
these creators that
what their start was and then i was like
oh what are you internet disney but he
didn't fit in i'm like that kind of
makes sense
yeah that does make sense
he's the animator he loves that he loves
storytelling so he's i guess that's the
only place there's
an animation yeah then he can like
channel that i saw a picture of him
directing edward scissorhands
and so you see johnny depp in the edward
scissorhands outfit and then you see him
in the edward scissor hands off
the scissors is he wearing this is
[Laughter]
robert smith from the cure he's just
like a bunch of [ __ ]
he's in it though like i love his movies
like
when you're watching it you're in his
mind yeah dude his batman i was like
you're in this
gotham city that i've never seen before
that was hilarious it was crazy dude
the 89 and the batman is that the oh is
that the first penguin
it was scary that's the only tim burton
movie i've ever seen actually really
never seen my verb before
i've never seen charlie a chocolate i'm
a big disney fan a big fish
you know i've never seen big fish big
fish is more than normal one steady
sports bride
no none of that nightmare before
christmas oh yeah uh
dog one i don't remember oh actually
edward says their hands too yeah
paranormal i get close bride at
nightmare before christmas mixed up yeah
that makes sense
claymationy yeah i love them both though
yeah
i was never a fan of a style either so
what do you do over at uh fighter and
kid and
initially i started off as an intern and
i was supposed to do like behind the
scenes work and then
update their social media platforms and
eventually brendan put me on
camera and i started doing current
events then i
started doing king the sting which is a
show that he does with
theo i am on camera for that
and now i do only fans that's tight
wait so you're not with them anymore no
i'm still with him uh that's the one but
you're more like on camera yeah i'm more
on camera now so i didn't have social
media
i've ever met yeah really we have so
many questions are you sick ass
feet just crushing it can you give us a
free she got shoes on
i have pretty nice feet feet aren't my
thing
but it became like an inside joke
because i think you can attest to this
like
every single just thinking about it
right now dude every girl
every girl has always been asked like
can i see your feet by like some guy
really he's into feet and it became a
joke because i talked about it on the
show
wait what happened what was your first
story it's like the
my dms would be crazy because it'd be
like oh show me your tits this and that
and then
out of nowhere it started being like i
want to see your feet what do the bottom
of your souls look like
the bottom of your soul and it just like
progress
you get it too yeah i talked about on
the show and suddenly it was like this
huge inside joke of like we want to see
cat's feet
i would hide my feet the only time i
would wear sandals was when
i'm in san jose like at home it's safe
yeah yeah controls
i never let anyone see my feet
how much does it cost to see your feet
now uh my subscription is ten dollars a
month and
reasonable one two two times a day two
times a day
wow dedicated it's that photos are your
feet you're just like after a while yeah
they're just
like it's the same what's your favorite
shot of your foot oh there's like a
drives the fans crazy there's a pose
that people love it's literally called
the pose where like uh it's the old
soccer pose where like you're on your
stomach you're doing this
and then your feet are in the back like
this
wow that's the money making sure is the
bottom of the soles
how do you find this out though people
have dm'd me and requests yeah like they
will tell you what they want to see
i think we've been telling you for how
many [ __ ] years tips can you do it
you would make a killing on it you would
make a cake i get desperate enough i'm
not desperate enough yet
you're not desperate for a hundred
thousand dollars
i'm not saying she's definitely not you
don't need to be you just need to be
smart a little bit
yeah i think it's definitely like
certain it's
for certain people i don't have that
intelligence yet it's not intelligence i
will say if you wanted to be on only
fans you could make a killing
real quick i'll hit you up real quick i
will i will give you numbers after this
just so you know but
uh casey wants to ask martin yeah and
you can buy a monasta martin if you
wanted to
oh my god i was one of those girls at
first when i heard it i'm like you know
what if you're an only fan selling
pictures of your
hoo-ha your feet whatever good for you
more power to you i love it
go get your bag but i felt uncomfortable
with it because i
have like a very predominantly male
audience and in my head i was like oh
are they gonna look at me like some type
of way whatever like it's going to be
weird
that's a good thing yeah it's
technically a good thing for what i'm
doing now
and i talked to my dad about it and my
dad's like here's the thing
if people are going to sexualize you
anyways and they want to make that
[ __ ] money like just make that money
why not
they're already your dad's awesome and
why is your dad so smart yeah
my dad's like old school vietnamese like
my mom was a coffee shop girl so like
this is kind of like the world like
like i don't have i don't think it's
like wrong morally or anything that like
show your body use your body
money
[Laughter]
i told him that once i make enough money
i'll buy him his dream car i'm trying to
buy him a corvette right now so i don't
know
if this is not the dream i don't know
what is dude i want him to adjust his
dream car as he gets closer
you know i said corvette that's 85 right
so like my friend shoots for uh one of
his models and before she wasn't doing
any only fans or whatever the first
month that she opened it up
and they're like not even nudes they're
just like seductive shoots right same
200 grand in that one month and after
that it's a consistent
six figures so you don't do nudes you do
sh
foot shots i will do uh feet shots and
then thrift straps so like anything
you'll see on instagram from like
uh so like i have done like wet t-shirt
stuff like if i'm not wearing a bra i'll
do like a wet t-shirt take a photo sell
it for like x amount of dollars to make
money
good for you do you sell each make that
bag even though it's a subscription
it's a subscription so i will post uh
like i will post one photo of my feet
every single day along with one thirst
trap
and then on everyone at home take milk
every other day i'll set out a
pay-per-view where i pull
i take more photos and it's like let's
say three to five photos in a package
and i will price it for a certain amount
and people can buy if they want to see
more so you get the standard two photos
every single day
and you'll get 14 photos in a week every
single time you work hard
buy more you can buy more and it's
optional wow
how do you know when the t-shirt's wet
enough huh
that's the nice thing i get to decide
how what the t-shirt is
and you get to choose if you want to buy
it but it's all like i control what i
want
you shopping wet yeah do you have a
photographer or no i do it all myself do
you just put it on a tri
tripod yeah like tripod i'll put it on
the stairs low cost
all profit dude that's [ __ ] amazing
do you do like a photo shoot like on a
sunday and then you're good for the week
or do you do it every day
yeah i need to start stockpiling i've
been doing it like once every single day
but stockpiling is probably the best
thing more efficient huh